us voters say immigration not inflation
is a top priority Harvard Harris poll so
uh post reports more voters are pointing
to immigration as their top issue
instead of inflation as the country goes
in the 2024 election a Harvard caps
Harris poll of 2,346 registered voters
that was released on Monday the survey
found that 35% of respondents had
immigration as their top concern and 32%
named the topic of inflation immigration
has jumped seven points from last month
I spent the holidays in Chicago they're
trying to build camps sad what do you
want to call them internment camps I
think that we should call them detention
camps for illegal migrants IL con camps
you could call them concentration camps
uh in New York Eric Adams is putting a
curfew on them yeah on the on the
illegals on the illegal on the shelters
that that house the illegal immigrants
so when when people say inflation the
only issue there is that these people
aren't aware of immigration correct
because if you go to someone who's jenzy
and they're like the rent is too too
damn High I say okay what's your
apartment say it's it's 70 sare ft I
spend
$2,000 I respond did you know that New
York is taking illegal immigrants and
giving them hotel rooms with full
bathrooms kitchenet and a
bed utilities everything's taken care of
while you struggle to pay your bills yep
immigration is an inflationary issue
absolutely 100% And and we should be we
should impeach May workus it's it's
absolutely mindblowing that we don't our
Congress who's controlled by the house
and or the Republicans control the house
and they don't even have enough backbone
to impeach May orcus right now this is
mindblowing they should all be Prim we
should be impeaching we should be
impeaching Joe Biden absolutely you you
know what the name of the game is you
know why like a state like West Virginia
would not try to investigate
tbp how much in federal dollars does
West Virginia receive exactly what it is
so it's so unfortunate some of these
smaller red States balance their budget
on the backs of the federal dollars
coming in that's really one of the
things they hold hostage over the small
states when it com comes to um like the
transgenders issue in schools in the
education stuff they depure Department
yeah but the Department of Education
that's why I'm proponent of getting rid
of the Federal Department of Education
well quite frankly I would abolish all
the three-letter agencies and return to
power back to the states and the local
communities where they belong the
Department of Agriculture was
interesting because they were saying uh
if you don't have these uh lessons about
whatever gender Theory ideology will cut
the money for uh subsidized lunch which
is then the and the bathrooms
bathrooms and and then they were like
which obviously means that the the
headlines would be like Republicans vote
against funding lunches for kids in need
like they know what they're doing and
they're being dishonest about it still
conservative small rural States pay the
price I will say I do think conservative
media got a good handle on that story
right from the beginning and said you
know uh Biden Administration is
threatening free school lunches for kids
over letting boys into girls' bathrooms
I thought we did a good job with that
the other thing too the department of
agriculture is a disaster they had this
whole thing where they were prioritizing
Farm loans for minority farmers and you
had a group of white Farmers sued and
they were like this is discriminatory
and you had a judge actually say you
can't fix current you can't fix past
discrimination with current
discrimination and Tom vilac was you
know handed his his loan papers back or
whatever but he should be impeached also
he's a disaster as well just nobody
really pays that much attention to the
Department of Agriculture because
there's so many I mean you were making
this point too it has gotten so big that
people don't realize that it's a
Department of Agriculture that oversees
school lunches or you know what I mean
they don't always know what the scope of
every agency is and part of that is
because we've had so many different
agencies that have been reshuffled and
reorganized that we can't keep track of
it and I'm sure they can't either which
is abolish them not not just defund them
abolish these three-letter agencies
return the power back to the States back
to the local communities back to you and
me and we the people because when it's
at a localized level there's
accountability there's no account we
have a bunch of unelected Bureau rats
right now sitting in DC running our
country behind the scenes with no
accountability how many staff people
just sitting there like ordering lunch
every
day yeah just hang out think about
office life think how expensive office
life there bureaucrats like Crossing off
the calendar being like I'm so much
closer to my government pension which
you know people need jobs people need to
work I'm not criticizing them for
that ultimately why is this job
available at all well only that my
answer to most of these people is name
one thing that the federal government
does better than the private sector
yeah well that's a good question right I
don't I can't name I can't name anything
that the government does better than
what the private sector would do yeah
yeah I don't see that oh hold on waste
money yeah waste money we're good at
that absolutely I gotta be honest like
the private sector is really good at
wasting money but the government man at
least there's accountability there
shareholders and well because it's not
their money and they haven't earned it
so you don't feel anything for losing
money if you didn't earn that money it's
just nothing and you can just ask for
more right at least with the private
sector You' have to eventually say your
shareholder is like so why we keep
losing money and with the government
they can say we lost money but no
worries you'll just give us more and
we'll raise taxes if we need imag
imagine being so bad at managing money
that you steal every citizen in the
country's money and you're still $34
trillion in debt that is just insane you
almost have to attempt to do that they
literally St everyone's money we didn't
stop at 34 and yeah we're 30 something
trillion dollars in debt we're more than
34 now because just keeps going up
there's
no here we go guys listen though this is
the this is the thing the originates in
the House Republicans have control of
the house we have to as I'm a republican
as Republicans we have to own this at
this point why pass another uh you know
we have a bunch of weak spinless
spinless jelly back Ranos representing
Us in Congress right now because they
want to just kick the can down the road
and sign another CR and allow all these
things that's currently happening to
continue happening instead of holding
the line MH that's what it comes down to
when you decided to run for Congress you
ultimately decided that you have to go
to the Federal Government Federal level
to cut off problems that are affecting
West Virginia rather than run for State
CU you did hold State yeah and and
unfortunately the federal government has
gotten so big that it does affect every
and I don't want that I want I want to
get rid of all that power at centralized
at the federal level and return it back
to the States where there's
accountability once again there are
there are limited roles the federal
government is supposed to have one of
them is securing our border and they
can't even do the one thing like not
that they can't exactly but instead of
worrying about all these other issues
that's not part of their their role they
should worry about the few things that
they're supposed to do which which is
that and you know I think that our
national SEC or the spending right now
and our everything you know our debt is
really a matter of national security at
this point I mean honestly think about
the the interest rate Al loone is going
to be like a trillion dollars a year on
interest alone coming up this is crazy
yeah I'll just print more money until
the economy implodes yeah I think that's
honestly I think that we're at the point
maybe that's what they're trying to do
they realize that there's no going back
at this point so they're just print it
and go like an acceleration and and then
think about all the money we're sending
to Ukraine and our own count is being
invaded we're sending money to other
countries to to secure their border well
and we're sending money all over the
world for really stupid things as well
like you know gender research in India
and all of these different kinds of
things uh that don't make any kind of
sense at all we send money to the UN and
then the UN goes out there and tell
tells all of these nations again you
know I hate to harp on it even though I
do all the time the UN goes out there
and the World Health Organization and
they go out there and they tell
everybody that they have to have more
gender equity and trans it's so sad that
we sent a single dollar to any of those
organizations it's absolutely ridiculous
think about they steal our money we're
in debt $34 trillion in debt they still
are money and they're sending it over to
these these organizations who quite
frankly hate us they do yeah they do
hate us we and so to like most of the
illegal immigrants coming in hate us yep
you know what is what is it that they
think they're going to get here W flag
of another country as they're coming
across our border not I mean like if you
know anyone who's taking a Citi like you
are ultimately supposed to pledge
loyalty to America you're supposed to
adopt the values you're supposed to
become patriotic on some level right and
that's not the bar when you migrate a
legally right when you assimilation
should be the goal and we don't we don't
have assimilation going on at all in
fact we have you know a woke Democrat uh
powerful officials who are saying that
people shouldn't assimilate because
America is bad and their their own
National Heritage and whatever is better
than America in which case like go home
go home people in feel that way okay we
have elected Democrats in Congress who
literally open say they hate our country
I yeah like what all of the AOC people
right her whole little crew yeah but
that means that their voters hear that
me their their voters hear that message
and resonate with it right well they
vote they vote for them they want them
they want that to
be why would you pick a to me I just
can't I can't wrap my mind around it why
you would pick an elected official that
is like I hate it here I don't believe
in anything I don't like these values I
actively think everything is bad and
therefore I will not work for betterment
and it's security like you are picking
instability do you how can you be okay
with that how can you inflict that on
your neighbors it must be what they want
well I think I think that our school
system has really unfortunately
indoctrinated a lot of the young people
into believing a lot of this they they
they they really do not like America a
lot of the young college age kids right
now we taught them to hate us and and
and well it's because our our public
universi in particular have been
basically transformed into creating
social justice Warriors and that's what
they're doing and that's why I think
that we need to withhold funding from
these universities if they want to push
the social justice Warriors and push
people to H our countries withhold that
money you can become a public or a
private university and fund it yourself
if you want to want to do those sorts
shut them down or shut them down and
completely I agree but I'm just saying
and I don't want to pay back the student
loans either I think that the
universities should pay back the student
loans with their own
endowments unilaterally just doing it
he's just doing it even though Supreme
Court said no yep and we should stop
issuing that what does that mean for
Texas like this is what I never get
about student loans which is that it's a
bad system we talk about constantly it's
it's handcuffing yourself to debt as you
launch into adulthood it's not a good
return on investment for anyone if you
were a small business as an 18-year-old
saying please give me money for this
can't get it you wouldn't get it and yet
we're still like well it's okay Biden's
going to forgive them and then we'll
just keep issuing them so we pretend
like we want to eradicate this problem
we being the federal government right
now by forgiving the debt but also we're
actually perpetuating the problem
because we still give out student loans
that we know are bad it it just makes no
sense and people are expected to say
like I'm not going to use any sort of
critical analysis to say this is a
broken system that's meant to entrap me
well before I got into real estate like
I was I was a school teacher that's kind
of what I went to school for what year
did you teach um what year what grade
you mean or I taught fourth grade and
then I taught some sixth grade okay but
um the thing is that's crazy about um
what's going on in our school system
right now it it would be less scary for
me if I thought these teachers were
pushing this social justice stuff from a
malicious standpoint the scariest part
about all this is they've been
indoctrinated into believing it's their
role and their moral duty to overstep
the parents and step in and push these
issues that's the scary part about this
whole well and they learned all that in
the grad schools that are funded by the
federal government that we should shut
down absolutely that's the scary part
honestly but what so do you think that
people are able to reconcile uh their
own sense of self with the lack of
Morality In America I feel like
ultimately one of the things that drives
uh an abandonment of traditional
American values is the internal
selfishness that people are really
cultivating these days yeah I definitely
you're coming from on that and I just
think that we are underestimating how uh
young minds you know 21 and under
specifically you know 25 and under how
they can be manipulated in some way I
mean when you're into an environment
where someone's placed in an authority
authoritative level like a professor and
they're telling you that this is you
know this is what you're supposed to do
as a teacher or whatever else and you
start to believe that and then you turn
on TV and billboards and everywhere it's
all around you all the celebrities that
you once again up on this platform and I
think that they've just been manipulate
I really do and and I think that people
are waking up to it though I mean I I
tell everyone that on the ballot in 2024
we have uh Joe Baden with uh tyranny and
uh you know poverty or you can have
freedom and prosperity with President
Trump yeah but I also wonder if it's
enough of an anecdote like being awake
to it and actually changing the way you
live and the way you approach your your
life is it enough to turn turn turn the
tithes I don't know I I really don't
know that answer because I don't know if
there's enough people who would be
willing to do and unfortunately there's
a lot of conservative teachers out there
who are afraid to speak not just
teachers and a lot of these they're
afraid to speak out though and I tell
everyone look you know what happened to
myself and and everyone else involved in
January 6 specifically they were using
us as examples to put fear into the
American people and I think we have to
remember that our rights do not come
from the government our rights come from
God our creator and the Constitution was
written to prevent the government from
infringing on our natural god-given
rights and so if we willingly give up
our free speech out of fear we've
already lost this battle we're in a
battle right now for the future country
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net